what's been like the empowerment mantra
that seen you through hard times I am a
strong woman and I've already gone
through a lot and seeing myself through
it I'm here and I'm healthy and I'm on
the other side and life is a journey so
[Music]
Josh Smith and today we're joined by the
og OC Queen herself and now she's
joining the hills which I'm dying for is
Mischa Barton I'm good how are you good
I am buzzing for the hills to come back
yeah and but what made you decide to
join it that's what I need to know I
mean it's just one of those things where
we're all at a time in our life which is
very different and I think there's
always been a lot of mystery around me
and it's kind of just fun to like have
people actually get to see me you know
because one of the most major essential
issues of the hills is actually
sisterhood oh it really is actually it's
like a very vivid and out there visuals
yeah it's girls to get all supporting
girls you know even though there's
obviously some fighting but it was like
teething problems yeah but um no you're
right it is yeah
what do you think the shades taught you
about sisterhood well I hadn't had quite
so many girlfriends before this you know
and so like it is funny when it's like
five women hanging out together there's
something to that I think one of the
crazy things for you is is that you
became so famous at a young age like I
mean you've been acting since like
basically de doll of your life but then
you've gone through so many different
cycles of Fame especially when you were
in the OSI which was like the biggest
show and everyone was obsessed with it
what do you think it's been the biggest
thing you've had to overcome with fame
just I guess having people talk about
every little aspect of your life I mean
there really was a time there where I
couldn't I couldn't do anything or get
away with anything or go like even leave
the house or do anything without having
to really think it through those were
the days weren't you'd have like a
caravan of paparazzi behind you like
seven cars following you things have
changed
it's just not like that anymore and so
they would make up whatever would sell
the photos and goal
with that you know whatever made it
interesting because going to the store
is pretty boring oh my gosh she picked
up an avocado man she bought paper dough
it must be such a crazy thing to be a
young women and have like seven vans of
paparazzi following you everywhere yeah
how did you really deal with that
because I can't imagine having my
private life become night entry save a
lot of humor
and travel I've got to be honest like I
moved back to London for a bit I went to
Paris I would travel I was doing movies
in India really seeing the world through
different people's perspective and eyes
really opens you up to why people are so
fascinated and the way they look at
Hollywood so when you put things in
perspective it makes it a little bit
easier - you've gone through so many
difficult things as well in the public
eye and you've come through it what have
you learned about yourself on that
journey would you so much I mean I did
start when I was like being that very
famous when I was only seventeen so your
20s are crazy anyway and then if you
magnify that I mean it was just wild
doing all of that in the public eye
there's not nothing I really haven't
started to learn about myself and pretty
resilient I've learned what has been sa
the biggest change you have seen in the
entertainment industry I mean it's just
nice to be in the post me too era now
it's nice that you know people are being
held accountable for their actions
that's a great feeling as a young
actress and as a woman that's really the
thing of our generation then it's like a
relief to be on the other other side of
that and that also there's a voice for
women no how have you dealt with talks
at mass going to you when you've come up
against there I'm a tough cookie so I
mean I think I've dealt with it with
some tenacity I would imagine or
something I think I'm I'm tough fine I
was raised that way
I was a family of girls and we were
raised to be tough and to stand up for
ourselves and so I guess I was never
afraid to do that when I was a bit
younger I didn't really understand the
power of female friendship
as much as I do now and now I really
really get it it's important
well amazing thank you so much for me I
am buzzing for the return and so glad
you're back on our screen they give for
more epic videos with such epic people
as Mischa Barton right here in ding ding
ding ding make sure you subscribe to
glamour UK channels right now
[Music]